resuelve para xy para ella y aquí
tenemos un par de ecuaciones menos 3 x 4
11 y 2 x igual a 13 y bueno quiero
resolver este par de ecuaciones por el
método de eliminación de suma y resta
sin embargo lo primero que quiero que te
des cuenta es que si yo sumo el lado
izquierdo de esta ecuación voy a obtener
algo que tiene que ver con las 10 no se
van a cancelar voy a obtener algo que
tiene que ver con x las x tampoco se van
a cancelar y por lo tanto no tengo en
ninguna de las dos variables que se
cancele entonces para aplicar el método
de suma resta lo que voy a hacer es
escalar una de estas dos ecuaciones y
para escalar una estas dos ecuaciones
date cuenta que si yo tuviera aquí abajo
un 3 bien entonces podría cancelar la
siguiente por lo tanto lo que voy a
hacer es multiplicar toda esta ecuación
de la ecuación de abajo por 3 de tal
manera que aquí me quedan tres bien para
que yo pueda cancelar la jem con la
ecuación de arriba y si multiplicó todo
esto por tres me queda 3 por 3 james 3
por 2 x es lo mismo que 6x y esto es
igual a 13 por 3 13 por tres es 39 hay
que multiplicar con 3 a ambos lados de
la ecuación no se te olvide todo lo
multiplicamos por 3
lo que estoy haciendo es escalando esta
ecuación y por lo tanto mi información
se conserva estas dos ecuaciones me
están diciendo lo mismo y bueno aquí
arriba voy a poner la primera ecuación
que es menos 3 x 4 x igual a 11 y ahora
date cuenta ya voy a poder eliminar la
variable y menos 3 james + 3 james se
van a cancelar y por lo tanto algo muy
padre va a pasar así que vamos a hacerlo
menos 3 viento más 3 james estos dos se
cancelan se van y después me quedan 4 x
+ 6 x es lo mismo que 10 x y del otro
lado me queda 11 + 39 lo cual es 50 y
ahora si yo divido entre 10 ambos lados
de la ecuación lo que me va a quedar es
que x es igual a 50 entre 10 lo cuál es
lo mismo que 5x igual a 5 es parte de la
solución de este sistema de ecuaciones
ahora lo que tengo que hacer es obtener
el valor de 10 sustituyendo el valor de
x en una de estas dos ecuaciones y voy a
utilizar la de abajo y me queda
james + 2 x 0 x vale 5 + 2 x 5 esto
tiene que ser igual a 3 y bueno 2 x 5 10
entonces me queda que ye más 10 es igual
a 13 y si yo
10 de ambos lados de la ecuación lo que
voy a obtener es que james es lo mismo
que 3 que va a ser igual estos dos se
cancelan y 1310 estrés perfecto
ya tengo que x igual a 5 de igualdad 3
es la solución de este sistema de
ecuaciones ahora con este par de valores
vamos a intentar comprobar que realmente
sean la solución por lo tanto vamos a
sustituir el valor de x y el legend en
ambas ecuaciones y me queda menos 3 por
james es decir menos 3 por 3 + 4 por x
es decir más 4 x 5 esto tiene que ser
igual a 11 y que me quedan menos 9 más
20 es igual a 11 perfecto está si se
cumple y en la otra me queda que james
más 2x es igual a 13 es decir que tres
más dos por cinco esto tiene que ser
igual a tres en lo cual pues sí es
cierto esto es igual a 13 y también se
cumple esta otra ecuación por lo tanto
estos dos valores x 5 y 3 es la solución
de este sistema de ecuaciones ahora bien
también había otra forma de pensar este
mismo problema déjame copia de la
primera cuestión que tengo aquí menos 3
james más 4 x igual a 11 y ahora
imagínate que lo que quisiéramos
eliminar en una primera instancia a la
equis y por lo tanto lo que necesito es
que este 2x se convierte en un menos 4 x
y para eso lo que esto hacer es
multiplicar toda la ecuación de abajo
por menos 2 escalar la ecuación de abajo
por menos 2 y recuerda que la
información se conserva y que me
quedaría menos 2 james menos 4x es lo
mismo que 13 x menos tras lo cual es
menos 26 y ahora sí sumó estas dos
ecuaciones estos dos se van aquí me
quedan menos 5 y m 5 y m y esto es igual
a 11 menos 26 lo cual es menos 15 y
ahora si yo divido ambos lados de la
ecuación entre menos 5 que me va a
quedar que james es igual a menos 15
entre menos 5 lo cual es 3 y qué creés
llegamos a la misma respuesta ya con
este valor de 3 podríamos sustituir este
valor de 3 en alguna de estas dos
ecuaciones para obtener el valor de x
pero date cuenta que de todas maneras
llegaríamos a que x es igual a 5
perfecto esto quiere decir que en un
principio si buscamos eliminar la x en
lugar de eliminar leyes llegamos a la
misma respuesta y con esto obtenemos dos
formas distintas de resolver el mismo
sistema de ecuaciones por el mismo
método nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo